you know i got a lot of play of being a
milf and i um
and i got a lot of sexual action
from american pie
mr finch
are you trying to seduce me
yes ma'am i am
[Music]
just you know i mean like i'm just
talking about the there were so many
benefits to doing that movie
i mean there were like
like 200 people that i would have
never had slept with
[Music]
you're dead
[Music]
yeah jennifer coolidge credits her turn
as stiffler's mom in american pie with
helping rack up her body count irl the
only person i was really sure i wouldn't
be sleeping with was stiffler
but
but i knew i would be sleeping with some
of the other boys the candid confession
comes from a new interview with variety
hi
and stifler's mom she's still got it
going on thanks to her work on hbo's the
white lotus
and he looks squeezing me in today it
was weird like everyone saw it everyone
saw that thing and um so that's pretty
exciting like it didn't you know i mean
i felt like
um that's the most popular thing i think
i've ever done where people just came
out of the woodwork i've had a couple
ex-boyfriends that i would never have
heard from
unless that happened you know like
people are really that shallow
you know now they're like
well i don't know why i just are just on
my mind
yup more than two decades after her pool
table rendezvous with finch
what's this
mom
[ __ ] break oh hey stiffler
jen's sex simple status is intact i was
so happy for american pie in the middle
thing but also first time anything what
an honor we'll find out if jen takes
home emmy gold for her work as aloof
heiress tonya on the hbo hit this
september and then in october she'll be
back on the small screen for season two
i hope i have lots of uh
romance and sex in this next one you
know i felt like i didn't get enough of
that in the first one
you were on fire last night
i was i do think there's one thing
i'm very sure of
i'm 100 sure people are gonna like white
lotus too
i don't know why i'm just 100 sure
[Music]
you